اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في ساعه اخباريه مفصله
من العربيه نبداها بالعناوين
رغم تمديد الهدنه عدو القتال بين الجيش
والدعم السريع تنتقل من الخرطوم الى
دارفور
وسط مناشدات الامم المتحده بالعوده الى
الحوار مستعد للمفاوضات مع البرهان شرطا
وقف اطلاق النار
عمليات الاجلاء مستمره وصول سفينتين
صينيتين الى جده واوكرانيا تجلي رعاياها
وروسيا لم تتخذ القرار بعد
دخان كثيف يملا سماء جزيره القرم جنوب
اوكرانيا بعد غاره بطائره مسيره
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا تغطيتنا للعربيه تغطيه
العربيه مستمره اذا للوضع المتفجر في
السودان منذ اسبوعين ورغم اعلان تمديد
الهدنه بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع لمده 72 ساعه بواسطه سعوديه
امريكيه تواصلت المعارك بالطائرات
والدبابات حتى مسائل جمعه في الخرطوم وفي
اقليم دارفور غرب السودان حيث ايقظ القتال
صراعا عمره عقدان المواجهات مشاهدينا حتى
الان خلفت مقتل قرابه
574 قتيلا مع الكشف عن مقتل 74 شخصا في
مدينه الجنينه وحدها مطلع الاسبوع
[موسيقى]
من الحرب في السودان لا صوت يعلو على صوت
الرصاص والمعارك تكوي ارضه دون حسم نهائي
لاي من الطرفين هدنه خامسه قد توقف اطلاق
النار نسبيا لكنها لن توقف الحرب جغرافيا
وساحه المواجهه الاساسيه تحركت غربا من
الخرطوم الى ولايه دارفور حيث بدا الجيش
السوداني بنقل جزء من معركته في الخرطوم
الى الجنينه عاصمه ولايه غرب دارفور
والسبب قطع الطريق على قوات الدعم السريع
ومنع نقل معدات عسكريه من الاقليم الى
الخرطوم اما ابعادها تستهدف قطع شرايين
الجغرافيا وتفريغ جيوب الاقليم من اي قوه
مسلحه تشكل دعما اللحمه لاندلاع
الاشتباكات في الجنينه عده دلالات
فالبرهان يريد تخفيف الضغط العسكري في
العاصمه الخرطوم اضافه الى تشتيت انتباه
قوات الدعم السريع لكن ما يخش الجيش
السوداني في دارفور هو تاثيرات البيئه
الاجتماعيه والجغرافيه المتشابكه حيث تنشط
قوات الدعم السريع بحكم الامتدادات
القبليه التي تصل تشاد وربما تنحاز لصالح
متي في لحظه معينه من المعارك مراقبون
حذروا من ان حياد الحركات المسلحه في
دارفور قد لا يستمر طويلا اذا اشتد القتال
في الاقليم ويمكن ان تنحاز الى الجيش او
الدعم السريع اما الرعب الاكبر عند
السودانيين يكمن في حصر القتال في دارفور
مجددا فاذا تفوق الجيش على قوات الدعم
السريع في الخرطوم لن يكون امام الاخيره
سوى التحسن في دارفور فتح جبهه دارفور
مجددا يعيد الى الاذهان اجواء الحرب
الاهليه السابقه خصوصا ان من صنعوا
انتصارات الامس اصبحوا اعداء اليوم اياد
حمود العربيه
بعد 15 يوما من القتال العنيف ابدا قائد
قوات الدعم السريع في مقابله مع قناه بي
بي سي استعداده لاجراء مفاوضات مع قائد
الجيش عبد الفتاح البرهان بشرط وقف اطلاق
النار وقال حميدتي لحياه الاذاعه
البريطانيه انه طالب بالهدنه منذ اليوم
الاول للحرب وان قواته بدات بفتح ممرات
انسانيه داخل مناطق سيطرتها
وفي تصريح للعربيه قال يوسف عزه المستشار
السياسي لقائد قوات الدعم السريع محمد
حمدانو قال ان قواته سيطرت على 90% من
ولايه الخرطوم وانها تستطيع الصمود في
المعارك لسنوات يوسف عزت لفتاه الى ان
المعركه فرضت على الدعم السريع وان وقف
اطلاق النار مرتبط بتنفيذ الجيش لذلك واكد
عزه في لقائه مع العربيه ان البرهان لا
يدير المعركه ولا يستطيع وقف النار على حد
قوله
قوات الدعم السريع قادره على الصمود قادره
على الصمود واثبتت خلال اسبوعين من الحرب
المتواصله انها ليست ميليشيا انها ليست
قوات مضره انها قوه منظمه تتبع خطط عسكريه
مرتبه لدينا وساطه من
امريكا ومدعومه من السعوديه لدينا وساطه
من العقاد لدينا وساطه من دول كثيره صديقه
ومنظمات ندرس كل هذه الخيارات ونحن
ولا نريد استمرار الحرب ولا نريد معاناه
شعبنا
اكيد مبادره تضمن ان يكون هنالك حل جذري
للازمه السودانيه هنالك حل يؤسس لسلام
دائم
بالمقابل اتهم الجيش السوداني قوات الدعم
السريع بادخال اسلحه وجنود لمستشفى
الخرطوم وبتحويل المستشفى وبعض المدارس
لثقنات عسكريه وجاء في البيان ان
المتمردين مستمرون بقصف الخرطوم وام درمان
لاجبار السكان على الاخلاء لافتا الى ان
القصف العشوائي مستمر في محيط قياده بحري
والقياده العامه والدفاع الجوي واضاف
الجيش انه نفذ عمليات اجلاء عبر مطاريها
لسيدنا وبورسودان لرعايا بعض الدول
هذا وحثت القوه المدنيه الواقعه لاتفاق
الاطري في السودان الطرفين على الالتزام
التام بوقف النار وشددت على ضروره التقيد
بتلك الهدنه التي وافق عليها قائد الجيش
عبد الفتاح البرهان وقائد الدعم السريع
محمد حمدان دقلو بصوره افضل من سابقاتها
كما اشارت الى انها تشد على ايدي قاده
الجيش والدعم السريع التي تعاطت بايجابيه
مع المبادره الامريكيه السعوديه اما فيما
يتعلق بالاوضاع في الجنينه باقليم دارفور
فاعتبرت ان المواجهات القبليه الحاصله
نتيجه مباشره للقتال الذي استعر منذ
الخامس بل منذ الخامس عشر من ابريل الجاري
بين القوتين العسكريتين الكبيرتين في
البلاد
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
رجعها صحيفه
الدعم السريع في الخرطوم بحكم امكانياته
العسكريه التي تفوق تلك التي لدى الدعم
السريع الا ان الا انها ايضا لم تستبعد
سيناريو اطاله امد نزاع على يد قوات الدعم
وتحويله الى حرب سنزاف
صراع على السلطه في السودان يخشى ان يتحول
الى حرب اكثر دمويه واطول امدا لكن طرفي
الصراع في العاصمه الخرطوم في وضعيتين
متباينتين فالقتال يجري بين مجموعتين
متفاوتتين في العدد والمعدات العسكريه
في تقرير لها رصدت قدرات الطرفين ومدى
امكانيه استمرارهما في القتال لفتره طويله
القوات المسلحه بقياده البرهان تملك اكثر
من 200 الف جندي جيش تقليدي يعرف شوارع
الخرطوم وتضاريسها مدرب على الدفاع عن تلك
المواقع بشكل جيد كما يدعمه سلاح الجو
بتشكيله من طائرات ماكس 29 السوفيتيه
ومروحيات ومدرعات وصواريخ عدا عن ادارته
لمصنع عسكري يزوده بالذخيره والعربات
المدرعه في الجهه المقابله يتوقع خبراء
عسك ان قوات الدعم السريع شبه العسكريه
تقاتل بما يقرب من 40 الف مسلح رغم ان
مصادر في الدعم السريع تقول ان عديدها
يقترب من 150 الفا وتعتمد هذه القوات على
تشكيله واسعه من مضادات الطائرات والعربات
المدرعه لكنها بطبيعه الحال لا تمتلك
سلاحا جويا غير ان هناك نقطه لصالح هذه
القوات بحسب
وهي الرواتب المجزيه مقارنه برواتب الجيش
السوداني وبحكم خلفيه تجنيدها كجماعه
مسلحه قبليه في دارفور وعلى حدود تشاد لا
درايه لقسم من عناصر الدعم السريع بتضاريس
العاصمه ولم يسبق ان توغلت فيها كما تتوغل
الان غير انها نجحت في ابتكار مسارات
جديده لتوفير الدعم بالذخيره لابقاء
عناصرها قادرين على خوض معارك استنزاف
طويله لكن يبقى التحدي القائم امام الدعم
السريع هو كيفيه السيطره على العاصمه
الخرطوم وهو امر لم يحدث في التاريخ
القريب من اي حركه خارجه عن الجيش او من
محاولات التمرد المتعدده في السودان عمر
العربيه
مشاهدي ينضموا الينا اللواء الدكتور امين
اسماعيل مجدوب الخبير الامني والاستراتيجي
بمركز الدراسات الدوليه اهلا بك دكتور
امين معنا في هذه النشره كما تابعنا يوسف
عزت المستشاره السياسي لقائد الدعم السرير
حمينتي قال ان قواته سيطره على تسعين في
المئه من الخرطوم هل يعكس ذلك حقيقه
الاوضاع والارض
صباح الخير ومرحبا بالساده المشاهدين ما
زالت الحرب النفسيه
وحرب الاعلام مستمره
الواقع على الارضي مختلف تماما وواضح انه
وقت الدعم السريع تعاني وتحاول
رفع الرؤيه من خلال مساعده تصريحات
العاصمه هي عباره عن مناطق الاستراتيجيه
مناطق عسكريه مناطق
وبالتالي من من يتحدث عن السيطره يحكم لكن
حديث في الاعلام والرسائل
لا اعتقد انه اكثر عرضه نفسيه طيب ولكن
قوات الدعم السريع ما زالت متواجده في
الخرطوم ما زالت ايضا كما يقال انها تطبق
حصارا ايضا على
القياده العامه وتهاجمها من حين لاخر لا
يبدو الجيش السوداني وكانه عاجز عن احكام
سيطرته على عاصمه تماما
[موسيقى]
رموز للنظام السابق ما قراءتك لهذا الطرح
وماذا دقه هذه المعلومات ايضا دكتور امين
من الواضح الحديث عن المدنيين يسيطرون على
القوات المسلحه طبعا ده حديث مردوق
والقوات المسلحه عند غيادته
في في القياده او في
مناطقين فقط وانما حتى عن عسكريين موجودين
حاليا وهم ينتمون للحركه الاسلاميه بحسب
وصفهم
الاسماء التي ذكرت الانيه اسماء مدنيين
طبعا
ذكرتها ولكن مساله انه في عسكريين ينتمون
الى ايدولوجيا ده كلام طبعا منذ الايام
الماضيه تم اسقاطه باعتبار انه جميع ضباط
وافراد القوات المسلحه اما قد يكون هناك
شيوعي ولا بحثي ولا
انصاري والاتحاد لهذه تقسيمات تخص كل شخص
عندما يفعل الى بيته لكن كضباط القوات
المسلحه هذا امر يدخل ايضا في الحرب
النفسيه محاوله
الصيغه بين افراد المسلحه بادعاء ان من
يسير الى الامر هم مجموعه مدنيه وحزب
بعينه وليس غيار المسلحه عموما حرب
الشائعه طبعا متوفره والحرب
المقاطعه قد يقول لك قائل ان الرئيس
السابق البشير يعني هو ضابط عسكري وفي ذات
الوقت هو من ضمن اعضاء الحركه الاسلاميه
وهذا يعني ان القوات المسلحه ايضا بها
عناصر لاحزاب ولي حركات مداريه اليس كذلك
نعم النظام السابق طبعا
الحديث عن القوات المسلحه
الجديد
وانضمامات الجديده
من الضباط الى التقاعد بالمعاش والان هي
تخوض معركه فاي حديث الان عن تشكيك في انه
لديها انتماءات قد يكون من قبل في تاريخ
السودان كان هنالك شيوعيونه
وخلايا كانت موجوده الاحزاب اخترقت القوات
المسلحه فهذا امر الان تجاوزه الزمن بصعود
النظام السابق شكرا لكم الدكتور امين
اسماعيل ميدوب الخبير الامير والاستراتيجي
بمركز الدراسات الدولي تحياتي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الجيش السوداني مشاهدينا حاول خلال
السنوات الماضيه تعزيز وجودها العسكري على
حدود الدول الجهراء للسودان ضمن
استراتيجيه هدفها الحفاظ على الامن وتجاوز
الاختلالات الامنيه التي يمكن ان تؤثر على
الطرق الحيويه في شرق القاره الافريقيه
حرب البرق الخاطفه تدخل اسبوعها الثالثه
في السودان والتداعيات يمكن ان تصل لدول
الجوار التي تشترك معه في حدود بريه
فالجيش السوداني طيله السنوات الماضيه
حاول حمايه حدوده والحفاظ عليها ضمن
استراتيجيه عسكريه تتماشى مع جغرافيا
المواقع بدايه من الشمال تحديدا الحدود
المصريه حيث توجد مناطق عسكريه تابعه
للجيش السوداني جنوبي مثلث حلايب في ولايه
البحر الاحمر ايضا تنتشر القوات السودانيه
في المثلث السوداني الليبي حيث توجد قاعده
مركزيه كبيره للجيش السوداني في الدوله
المضطربه امنيا كما ان تشاد التي تشترك
بحدود تزيد عن الفين كيلو متر مع السودان
تنتشر في حدودها قوات سودانيه شاديه
مشتركه هدفها تامين الحدود من المرتزقه
وفي افريقيا الوسطى التي تمزقها الحرب
يوجد الجيش السوداني ضمن نقاط تفتيش
عسكريه فقط اما على الحدود السودانيه التي
يمكن ان تتحول لقاعده لتدفق السلاح ينتشر
الجيش السوداني ضمن نقاط تفتيش كبرى في
كسلا والحدود المتاخمه مع اريتريا ضمن
حاميات عسكريه وفي اثيوبيا التي تخوض مع
السودان نزاعا حدوديا غير محسوم ينتشر
الجيش السوداني في منطقه الفشقه التي تقع
في ولايه القضارف وايضا في منطقه القلابات
وولايه النيل الازرق وفي جنوب السودان
هناك العديد من المناطق العسكريه ينتشر
فيها الجيش شمالي ابياي وجنوبي كردفان
وولايه النيل الابيض
فالجيش السوداني حاول خلال السنوات
الماضيه اتباع استراتيجيه تحكمها ضوابط
عسكريه لتعزيز وجوده على الحدود
ومن الخرطوم مشاهدينا ينضم الينا الكاتب
الصحفي شوقي عبد العظيم
وكيف قرات بدايه تصريحات قائد قوه الدعم
السريع محمد حمدان
والذي اشار فيها الى استعداده الجلوس الى
طاوله المفاوضات مع البرهان شريطه وقف
اطلاق النار
نعم اهلا وسهلا ان الواضح منذ فتره في
بدايه هذه المعارك انا كاللغه حافه جدا من
حميدتي قائد الدعم السريع كانت اللغه حاده
وكانت العبارات ربما حتى فيها بعض
الاساءات وهكذا ولكن اعتقد ان هنالك تبديل
للخطه منذ فتره قريبه بدات دعم السريعي
يسعى لكسب المجتمع الدولي بان يكون هنا
اكثر مرونه ان يبدا دائما بطرح الهدن
ويوافق عليها فورا يريد ان يخاطب المجتمع
الدولي حتى كان حريص جدا على تسليم
المحتجزين المصريين ثم في مساله اجلاء
الرهائن كل ذلك كانت رسائل للمجتمع الدولي
ثم لذلك يريد ان يكسب الداخل السوداني
ايضا المجتمع السوداني بان يبدو وكانه هو
لا يريد الحرب وذكر هذه اكثر من مره لانهم
في القتال وهكذا شيء اخر ايضا مساله
المعارك وطول المعارك ايضا لديه تاخير في
خطاب قائد الدعم السري
كل دعاه الى تحول الى هذا التحول في اين
يجد اكثر مرونه واكثر تقبلا لمقترحات
المجتمع الدولي وان يبعد من القتال ودائما
يقول انه هذا القتال فرض عليه فاعتقد ان
هذه كلها تدخل جزء منها الصوره للدعم
السريع نفسه وبقائد الدعم السريع يحاول ان
يرسم صوره اكثر مرونه واكثر مبنيه واكثر
علاقه بالمجتمع وما يؤكد ايضا ما تفضلت
بالاشاره اليه سيد شوقي هو حديثه ايضا عن
فتح اخواته ومراد انسانيه فيما يفهم منه
التاكيد ايضا على اهتمامه بالجوانب
الانسانيه رغم المواجهات الحاصله حاليا
لكن هذه الروايه سيد شوقي ايضا تقابلها
روايات اخرى سواء من الجيش السوداني ومن
المواطنين على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
تتهم فيها قوات الدعم السريع بتنفيذ
عمليات سلب ونهب في خرطوم ومناطق اخرى
بصفتك متواجدا في في الارض وشهد ايضا على
الاحداث
اين تسمع الحقيقه
تعرضت منازلهم الاخلاق
والاستيلاء عليها من قوات الدعم السريع
هذا حدث في مناطق مختلفه انا لدي اصدقاء
مباشرين سمعت منهم هذه الروايات ولكن
الروايات الاخرى حول كثير من الانتهاكات
لا احد الصوت كان يتقطع قبل قليل يعني ما
هي الروايه التي استمعت اليها من معارفك
بعض بعض الزملاء في خرطوم اثنين خرطوم
ثلاثه في بعض المناطق المجاوره
هل تسمعني
طيب
سنحاول العوده اليه في سياق هذه النشره
مره اخرى
مشاهدينا
في مقابله خاصه مع العربيه نجد السودانيين
للعوده الى الحوار واكد ان الامم المتحده
ستعمل بكل جهد هذه الوصول لحل لازمه
السودان
ابعث رساله للشعب السوداني لكل السودانيين
الذين يسمعون اود ان اعبر عن تضامن العميق
وتضامن الامم المتحده عندما كنت المفوضه
الاعلى للاجئين زرت السودان عده مرات وكنت
مندهشا من حسن الضيافه لدى الشعب السوداني
كنا نرى لاجئين من تشاد واريتيريا واحيانا
يشاطرونهم بما توفر لديهم من موارد من
خلال نظام يعتمد على الاخويه رؤيه هذا
الشعب الكريم والشجاع وهو يعاني امر يبعث
على الصدمه ويزعجني للغايه هناك جمله من
الامور التي يجب ان نقدمها الامم المتحده
لن تتخلى عن السودان وستفعل كل ما بوسعها
من اجل تامين الظروف الامنيه لتقديم الدعم
الانساني الشعب السوداني المفوضيه العليا
لشؤون اللاجئين التي عملت بها لمده عقد من
الزمن فاعله هناك وستضمن استقبال اللاجئين
هذا صراع يجب ان ينتهي وسنفعل كل ما
بوسعنا للتواصل الى وقف دائم لاطلاق النار
ليعود هذا البلد الى الحوار والاستقرار
وتمهيد الطريق الانتقال الديمقراطي الشعب
السوداني كان يحارب من اجل هذا الامر
هذه هي الهدنه الثالثه خلال الساعات
الاثنتين والسبعين الاخيره انا والاتحاد
الافريقي وايجاد وجامعه الدول العربيه كنا
نهيب بوقف اطلاق النار ورغم انخفاض منسوب
القتال لكن الهدنه لم تصمد وتم استئناف
القتال اكثر من 1200 من موظفي الامم
المتحده تم نقلهم عبر بورد سودان اود ان
اشكر الاطراف تحدثت معهم لكن للاسف يستمر
القتال يجب ان نتحد كاسره دوليه ونعمل مع
الاتحاد الافريقي وايجاد ورئيس كينيا
ورئيس جنوب السودان ورئيس جيبوتي يجب فعل
كل شيء من اجل خلق ظروف مواتيه والتحدث مع
البرهان وحميدتي واطراف اخرى انها مساله
شعب يطمح الى قياده مدنيه سياسيه
المتحده لن تتخلى عن السودان وستفعل كل ما
بوسعها لتوفير الظروف الامنيه من اجل
تقديم الدعم الانساني للسودانيين
الامم المتحده لن تتخلى عن السودان وستفعل
كل ما بوسعها لتوفير الظروف الامنيه من
اجل تقديم الدعم الانساني للشعب السوداني
هذا صراع يجب ان ينتهي وسنفعل كل ما
بوسعنا للتوصل الى وقف دائم لاطلاق النار
ليعود هذا البلد الى الحوار والاستقرار
وتمهيد الطريق الانتقال الديمقراطي الشعب
السوداني كان يحارب من اجل هذا الامر
وفي مقابله اخرى مع العربيه اكدت مندوبه
بريطانيا في الامم المتحده ان بلادها تهدف
للحصول على دعم مجلس الامن لمقترحات
الاتحاد الافريقي وايجاد فيما يخص الوضع
الحالي في السودان
ما فعله هو الحصول على الدعم الكامل من
مجلس الامن لمقترحات ايجاد والاتحاد
الافريقي للتقدم نحو وقف اطلاق نار ومن ثم
العوده للعمليه السياسيه
اول ما يجب العمل عليه هو المساعدات
الانسانيه ونحن كبريطانيا خصصنا 250 مليون
استرليني لنحو 50 مليون شخص بحاجه لمساعده
انسانيه فوريه الامم المتحده ايضا بقيت في
السودان لتقديم المساعدات اما الخطوه
التاليه هي العوده للعمليه السياسيه
الامين العام المتحده تحدث ايضا عن عدم
حصوله حتى الان على تفاصيل مبادره منظمه
في السودان المنظمه هي واحده من مكونات
الاليه الثلاثيه التي تقوم ايضا الامم
المتحده والاتحاد الافريقي التغيير التالي
مشاهدينا يرصد لنا مزيد من التفاصيل حول
الاليه الثلاثيه واللجنه الرباعيه وما
تحاول فعله لحل الصراع الدائر حتى قبل
اندلاعه
قبل اكثر من ثلاث سنوات فشل التوافق بين
المدنيين والمجلس العسكري في السودان في
اداره الفتره الانتقاليه وادى التوتر الذي
طغى بين المقاولين الاعتقال المجلس
العسكري لعبد الله حمدوك رئيس الحكومه
انذاك ووضعه قيد الاقامه الجبريه وبدا
المشهد في السودان شديد الضبابيه والتعقيد
فسعت الاليه الثلاثيه في السودان والمؤلفه
من ممثل الامين العام للامم المتحده
ورئيسي بعثه
والاتحاد الافريقي بالاضافه الى الهيئه
الحكوميه لتنميه وسط وشرق افريقيا
الى ايجاد حلول تمهد الاتفاق ايطالي بين
القوى المدنيه والعسكريه في السودان
يتناول قضايا جوهريه تشمل تشكيل حكومه
مدنيه والاتفاق على قضيه العداله
الانتقاليه وتقييم اتفاقيه السلام وكذلك
الاصلاح الامني والعسكري لكن اصطدمت
الاليه الثلاث كثيره ابرزها ارتبط بسنوات
دمج الدعم السريع داخل مؤسسه الجيش كما
واجهت معضله انسحاب الجيش من الحوار ما
اجبر الاليه على تعليقه عقب هذا التعقيد
نشطت المجموعه الرباعيه في السودان والتي
تتشكل من السعوديه والامارات والولايات
المتحده وبريطانيا في محاوله مع الاليه
الثلاثيه في لعب دور اكبر في الوساطه بين
المكون المدني والعسكري لتقريب وجهات
النظر وايجاد ارضيه مشتركه تسمح لها
بتسهيل الحصول على الدعم الذي يحتاجه
السودان لمواجهه ازماته الاقتصاديه حنان
المصري العربيه
مشاهدي مره اخرى الى الكاتب الصحفي شوقي
عبد العظيم اهلا بك من جديد وقبل انقطاع
الاتصال كنت تتحدث عن عمليه السلب والنهب
التي حدثت في بعض المناطق في الخرطوم
يمكنك ان تكمل بداته
نعم انا قلت
لك
يعني يؤكد جميع الروايات ولكن لدي اصدقاء
او معارف بعضهم
على منازلهم في مطار الخرطوم من قبل قوات
الدعم السريع ولكن لا نستطيع ان نقول هذه
الجرائم التي يتحدثون عنها هي ربما هي قام
بها الدعم
ولكن المؤكد ان بعض المنازل
انها
طيب يبدو ان هناك مشكله ايضا في الاتصالات
بسبب المواجهات الدائره في الخرطوم
وشبكات الاتصالات سنحاول العوده اليك مره
اخرى شوقي في حال تحسن الوضع
في الاثناء مشاهدينا شدد سفير السودان لدى
واشنطن محمد عبد الله ادريس مقابله مع
العربي شدد على ان بلاده ترحب بكل الوساطه
لوقف القتال الا انها تفضل الوساطات
الاقليميه والافريقيه تحديدا
ولكنها
تعوي الكثيرا على المبادرات والوصفات
الاقليميه والوساطات من داخل المحيط
الاقليمي الى السودان من داخل القاره
الافريقيه ومن خلال الاتحاد الافريقي يجب
ان تكون الحلول حلول المشاكل الافريقيه
بواسطه الافريقيين بايدي افريقيا ونحن
كحكومه سودانيه نلتزم بما يلتزم به
الاتحاد الافريقي
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر
في هذا السياق قال العقيده المتحدث الرسمي
لحرس حدود السعوديه في تصريحات للعربيه ان
حرس الحدود في ميناء جده سخر جميع
الامكانيات البشريه والماديه والتقنيه
لاستقبال الضيوف عمليه الاجلاء من السودان
حيث وصلت سفينتان صينيتان اللتان تحملان
رعايه من الصين وباكستان
حرس الحدود مهام من ضمن الاعمال والمهام
المنوطه بوزاره الداخليه والقطاعاتها
المشاركه في تقديم المساعده في عمليات
الاجلاء
المواطنين او الرعايه الدول الصديقه
والشقيقه من السودان الى ميناء جده
الاسلامي والتي سنحت لهم حكومه المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
عمليات الاجلاء الى حتى وصولهم الى جده
ومن ثم المغادره الى بلادهم بكل امن
وسلامه يقوم حرص حدود بالعديد من المهام
من ضمنها حفظ الامن والسلامه داخل الميناء
وكذلك
المنطقه المحيطه به كما يقوم حرس حدود
بتنظيم الحافلات والمركبات داخل الميناء
لتحقيق الامن والسلامه للجميع طبعا سخر
حرس حدود جميع الامكانيات الماديه
والبشريه والتقنيه لخدمه هؤلاء القادمين
الى المملكه العربيه السعوديه
[موسيقى]
اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه الاوكراني عن اجلاء
87 من مواطنيها معظمهم من الطيارين والفني
الطائرات وعائلاتهم وذلك ضمن 138 مدنيا في
المجمل من بينهم مواطنون من جورجيا وبيرو
من جهه اخرى لم تعلن روسيا بعد عن اي
اجراء لاعضاء سفارتها او رعاياها من
الخرطوم وقال المتحدث باسم الكريم ان
الروسي في السودان على اتصال وثيق بموسكو
مؤكدا ان المشاوره تجري على مدار الساعه
في هذا الاطار اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه
والدفاع في فرنسا في بيان مشترك ان طائره
فرنسيه اجلت موظفين من امم المتحده
والمنظمات الانسانيه من السودان وجددت
فرنسا مناشدتها الاطراف السودانيه لوقف
الاقتتال والعوده للحوار السياسي يذكر انه
هو منذ بدء عمليات الاجلاء من السودان
اجلت القوات المسلحه الفرنسيه اكثر من الف
شخص من بينهم 216 فرنسيا
بدورها اعلنت بريطانيا عن نهايه الرحلات
الاجلاء من السودان اعتبارا من اليوم
السبت وذلك بعدما اجلت اكثر من 1500 شخص
حتى الان وكانت الحكومه البريطانيه اعلنت
الثلاثاء الماضي عن بدء اجلاء مواطنيها
بعد موافقه طرفي الصراع على وقف اطلاق
النار لمده اثنتين وسبعين ساعه واعطاء
الاولويه لاجلاء من يحملون جوازات سفر
بريطانيه والاسر التي تضم اطفالا وكبار
السن الذين يعانون من ظروف صحيه
اجلت تشاد في غضون 48 ساعه
351 من مواطنيها الذين خسروا في القتال
الدائري في السودان بعد وصول طائره ثالثه
الى انجومينا على متنها 130 راكبا وكشف
المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه ابراهيم ادم
محمد عن استقبال 130 عائدا بينهم 15 طفلا
واربعه وثلاثون مسنا رافقتهم فرق وكاله
الهجره التابعه للامم المتحده التي احصل
عددهم هذا هو كانت رحلتان جويتان مخصصتان
الاجلاء وصلت الى العاصمه جميعنا مساء
الخميس من بورسودان وكان على متن
الطائرتين
221 شاديا
مشاهدينا ينضم الينا الصحفي صالح ابو
علامه اهلا بك سيد صالح معنا في هذه
الساعه الاخباريه والحديث ايضا يتم الان
عن انتقال المعارك من الخرطوم الى مناطق
في اقليم دارفور الذي كان ايضا مضطربا
لاشهر العده بسبب الصراعات قبليه بسبب
ايضا مشاكل يعاني منها الاقليم عديده كيف
يمكن ان الاوضاع في الوقت الحالي
[موسيقى]
جدا دارت في احيانا متفرغه
خلفت هذه الاحداث نزوح كبير جدا
للمواطنين كما تم حرق لبعض مراكز الايواء
داخل المدينه لكن اليوم هنالك هدوء في
المدينه هدوء في مدينه القنينه ما زلت
مظاه
ر السفر مظاهر
ما زال البعض يتربص
بالمواقع الاستراتيجيه
والاسواق وما تبقى من مؤسسات حتى الان لا
توجد قوه تدخل بين الطرفين المستارعين في
حتى هذه اللحظه
في وقت سابق ارسال قوه تدخل بين
المتحاربين في الجنينه ولكن حتى الان هذه
هو لم تصل مدينه هنالك ترقب للوصول هذه
القوات في اي وقت على الارض الان تنشر هذا
المبادرات الاهليه وبعض يعني الذي دخلوا
في هذا الصراع كمحيدين بين الطرفين بهدف
تحسين الوضع الالباني وبهدف ايضا لم اتبقى
من
[موسيقى]
مؤسسات ولم تبقى من الاسواق التي تم حرقها
الان
[موسيقى]
خلال الايام الماضيه هذه
الجهود الاهليه وربما
خلال ساعات الماضيه في هدنه يعني
الى نهايه هذا اليوم
اجلاء القتلى داخل الاحياء حتى الان هناك
يعني داخل الاحياء حتى هنا حتى الان هناك
يسلموا الى الى زبي
بالجنينه هنالك ايضا معسكرات داخل المدينه
ليحملون سلاح ويتربصون ببعض الاماكن ايضا
تحتاج الجهاز
للوصول اليهم ولعقد هدنه ايضا مع جميع من
يحمل سلاح داخل مدينه
طيب هذا ما يتعلق بالجنينه ماذا عن بقيه
المدن الكبرى في دارفور
مثلا في مدينه
من حركات الكفاح المسلحه نشرت قوات
تباشر بمدينه
هنالك ايضا دهود كبيره من الشباب اليمن
على المتفلتين من دخول الاحياء وذلك بعمل
خنادق ووضع كتل السرطانيه في مداخيل
الطرقات المؤديه الى الاحياء هذه الحيله
ساهمت مساهمه كبيره في عدم دخول
السيارات في عدم هؤلاء المتفلتون سيصطلح
ينتمون الى طرف بعينها والى فصيل مسلحه
الى اي جهه يمكن
يكون انتباؤهم
نعم عندما دارت دار اختراع في في دارفور
في مدن دارفور اتت اعداد كبيره من خارج
المدن في سابق كانت يعني الاحداث في
دارفور تقع خارج المدن الكبيره ولكن
المعذره للاسف ايضا فقدناه الصوت ونعتذر
مشاهدين عند اضاءه الصوت لسوء الخدمات في
الخرطوم وفي السودان بسبب الاوضاع التي
تمر بها البلاد حاليا نعود الى سياق هذه
النشره المشاهدين حيث شكلت الحكومه
الاثيوبيه لجنه وطنيه لتسهيل عبور
النازحين من الصراع الدائر في السودان
ودعت الحكومه الاثيوبيه اطراف الصراع
السوداني لوقف الاقتتال وانهاء معاناه
المدنيين واكدت دعم هذه الحلول السودانيه
من دون تدخل اطراف خارجيه
نتابع بقلق بالغ تطورات ما يجري في
السودان وقد قمنا بتشكيل لجنه وطنيه
تتراسها الخارجيه الاثيوبيه بالتعاون مع
جهات رسميه اخرى وقد قمنا بارسال فريق الى
الحدود مع السودان للقيام بتسهيل عبور
النازحين من الحرب الدائره هناك ونامل ان
يحل السلام في السودان في اقرب وقت ممكن
الصراع الدائر في السودان له تاثيرات
سلبيه على المفاوضات الثلاثيه في قضيه سد
النهضه ولا يمكن استئناف المفاوضات ما لم
يحل السلام في السودان ويكون هناك تركيز
تام من الجانب السوداني هذا الوضع يجعلنا
ننتظر حلول السلام في السودان
العربيه والحدث داخل مدينه بورسودان في
شرق السودان في هذا المركز الرئيس لحصر
وتنسيق وتوفيقي اوضاع مئات الاسر التي
وصلت الى شرق السودان في طريقها الى خارج
البلاد عديد الجاليات وعديد رعايه الدول
الاوروبيه والعربيه والافريقيه وصلت الى
مدينه
اوضاعها في هذا المركز كما تتابعون هذه
الاوضاع وهذه الصور وهذه المشاهد لمئات من
الاسر ما زالت تنتظر حتى الان مرت عليها
اكثر من خمسه ايام وهي تنتظر توفيق
الاوضاع والمغادره عبر البواخر والقطعه
الحربيه البحريه التي تصل تباعا من
المملكه العربيه السعوديه ومن عديد الدول
في المنطقه هذا المركز هنالك جهاد تشرف
على عمليه الحصر وعمليه توثيق الاوضاع
سواء كان من السفاره السعوديه او من
الشرطه السودانيه او اداره الجوازات
بالسودان لتوفيق
عديدي الرعايه والجاليات التي وصلت الى
شرق السودان هذه العمليه مستمره مع
استمرار هذه العمليه تزداد صعوبه الاوضاع
هنا داخل هذا المركز وفي محيط هذا المركز
وداخل هذه المدينه مع ارتفاع اعداد
الواصلين الى مدينه بورسودان والى شرق
السودان اكثر من 4000 سوري وصلوا الى هذه
المدينه اكثر من 1500 طالب ومن رعايه دوله
اليمن وصلوا الى هذه المنطقه مما يفاقم
الاوضاع ويصعب كذلك عمليه توفيق الاوضاع
والاجراءات المتبعه حتى يغادر السودان
خلال الساعات المقبله ومع استمرار هذه
الاجراءات يستمر تدفق المئات من الاسر الى
مدينه بورسودان بشرق السودان في طريقهم
لمغادره البلاد نزار لقناتي العربيه
والحدث مدينه بورسودان الشرقيه السودان
انسانيه مشاهدينا اكد برنامج غذاء العالمي
في بيان ان الوضع في السودان اصبح كارثيا
وان اسعار المواد الغذائيه في السودان
ارتفعت بشكل صاروخي واكد برنامج الغذاء
العالمي التزامه باستئناف عمليته في
السودان داعيا الى ضروره التوقف القتال
ولفت برنامج الغذاء العالمي لانه يجري
تقييما للوضع الامريكي في السودان لتحديد
المواقع الهادئه لتقديم المساعدات
[موسيقى]
يعود الينا مره اخرى من اقليم دارفور
الصحفي صالح ابو علاء اهلا بك صالح من
جديد وكنت تتحدث قبل انقطاع الاتصال عن
المتفلتين الذين شرطي لانهم ياتون من
مناطق خارج المدن الكبرى وايضا ينفذون
عمليات سلب يمكنك اكمال الفكره
نعم يعني تاتي اعداد كبيره من خالد المدن
تحمل السلاح درجات الناريه فاذا الملكة من
يمتلك عرفات الرباعي
يعملون على كلب ونهب المؤسسيه يعني هذه
المره الاحداث الاخيره
كبير جدا
للمنظمات
ابدا لا يتم اكتشافها
ثم تامين فقط المنظمات في شمال دارفور
بواسطه يعني قوات تدع لحركات الكفاح
المسلحه مسار دارفور تم تامين مقرات
المنظمات في الفاشل حتى تم اجلاء ايضا
من يعملون في الامم المتحده في ولايه
في بعض مدن دارفور مثلا في نياله وفي
الجنينه تم تدمير مقرات المنظمات
تماما الوضع في دارفور يحتاج الى من يفرض
السيطره على ارض الواقع من يتدخل
عندما تحدث مثل هذه الاحداث يعني يتم
تكوين قوه مشتركه من الدعم السريع من
المسلحه ومن الشرطه تعمل على تامين المدن
لكن
يعني الخلاف الاخير في السودان والمعارك
التي دارت جعلت الجيش يتمركز حول قواعده
في الولايات دارفور السريع ايضا يكون
منتظم
في القاعده الخاصه به بدر ولا يوجد ان
يدخل بين الناس اليوم الوضع في دارفور
يحتاج اكثر الى التدخل يحتاج اكثر الى
الفصل بين المتحاربين يحتاج الى من يقف
على ارض الواقع ويمنع المعارك التي يمكن
ان تتصور اكثر ويمكن ان تدخل في صراع كلي
في هذا الاقليم
طيب هذا ما يتعلق بالوضع الامني ماذا عن
الجانب الخدمي اتحدث هنا ايضا عن المواد
التموينيه على الاغذيه الادويه ما مدى
توفرها وتقديمها للمستشفيات ايضا لخدماتها
للمرضى
معروف وانا يعني عاصمه السودان الخرطوم
عاصمه السودان هي المركز الذي تستمد منه
ولايات دارفور اسئله الاساسيه والان في
الخرطوم وهنالك يعني بعض الجهود لوصول
الممثله الاساسيه ولكن عمليات السلب
والناهب في الطرق عمليات السلب والناس حتى
داخل ولايه الخرطوم تمنع وصول عدد كبير من
السلع الاساسيه وتمنع ايضا وصول الادويه
الوضع الانساني في الولايه
طيب يبدو اننا مره اخرى بضيفنا من اقليم
دارفور الصحفي صالح ابو علامه شكرا لك
السيد صالح
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات